you can also um you can talk to me about
anything you want
yeah we are back again after my left
comedian Gary cannon to my right Steve
Byrne Pittsburgh Pennsylvania
yeah in the middle joining us today from
San Diego you know him you love him
MADtv he plays characters with Down
syndrome league thank you
he was one for 25% of a touring company
known as the Kings of Comedy my hero
Healy every money in studio but they
have me here guys I really appreciate it
and he's got his own show here on all
things comedy as well yeah thank you I
really appreciate your podcast is the
good pretty good yeah but it's Tiger
Belt tiger yeah talk about yeah yeah
tell Tiger bone how long you been doing
it we're like 12 13 episodes in you know
I am my girlfriend at a podcast and then
she was just like you when do with me I
go alright and then we started doing
it's fun she do a podcast with your
girlfriend yes in my uh in my condo and
it's just we do it at Midnight's at
midnight will start and it will release
it Wednesday that's cool yeah what do
you talk about Thank You vodcast um
debauchery really you know thing III
really talk about everything that um all
my problems and my sexual problems I
have a lot of sexual problems and I do I
be the list goes on and I have a lot of
life problems and we just talk about
stuff like that about my character
defects about like you know what my
goals are how lazy I am I talk about
video games I love video games just
everything but I'm an open book right so
if you wanted hey you know you've had
sex with prostitutes
sure okay because people say well my
parents go well you have to do that I
did it I think that's what that's why I
love you as much as I do
as crazy as you you're you are totally
honest you have always been an open book
you don't like a lot of guys would be
like if they if they slept with a
prostitute they would never bring that
up to people but you you don't care her
no I do care and I think it's immoral
you don't care if people know like
you're you're very open in that regard
grace I do that yeah yeah I mean if I
something that I did even though I'm
embarrassed by it it's like you know
maybe if I expose the world to it that
maybe I'll stop my behavior but I mean I
would just say this I've never cheated
on any girlfriend of my I go crazy
between relationships I go hog-wild
right yeah like I was in Thailand and I
was shooting this really bad movie with
Michelle Yeoh from Crouching Tiger
Hidden Dragon and grown-ups 3 and we
don't when I had dinner with Michelle
Yeoh and a couple people and I just
realized because she's an older
sophisticate she's like the middle
Streep of Asian actresses right right
you don't want to have I'm like what do
I do and I just ended up going to a
brothel every night I took my per diem I
took a moped to this place called your
fur do to this place called Amsterdam
and I'm not there for two months and
then you know I like going to a brothel
like catching anything or no I tell you
why I believe that Koreans are
unbreakable
okay we're evolved well from a CDS I
think I am I think that's my power if
they did a movie right yeah that's my
power that would be your so you're
you're maybe power would be like this
would be a bola maybe that's the thing
that gets me but like if I was a
superhero that well so so maybe like we
if someone needs to have sex with
Charlie Sheen
infiltrate and get this information from
your like I'll do it I don't kind of
wait what kind of per game are you
getting on this movie I mean are you
getting or you're getting like 75 bucks
so is that a good day but for them if
that's like a million dollars right so
you're taking the money that you should
be using for like sundries and you're
spending it on sex yeah but those years
ago guys I'm in a relationship and I
how's your relationship now amazing like
it's probably the best relationship I've
ever been in validating two and a half
years Wow
yeah do you foresee you walking down the
aisle or oh you do it's the first time
I've ever said like I'm gonna probably
marry her and then number two I'm
probably gonna have children with her oh
wow this is quite a change yeah I've
never I've never said that before my
Bobby Lee I know yeah cuz you used to
say I'm gonna hug it a die alone yeah I
mean that is a fantasy
yeah I like being 70 and then finding my
skeleton with like Xbox 360 controller
in my hand happened he was playing
Fallout 9 you know a Los Angeles you are
a sonic game but you you were telling me
the other day you and Eric Griffin from
workaholics yeah and your brother I
think play destiny together yeah yeah
you tell me it logs your hours how many
hours did you log into that game 1400
1400 dude I'm gonna die you could have
learn to play the guitar yeah I know
five thousand become an expert I know
how to play the guitar come on I do
guitar here yeah yeah play a little
piano I this is this thing that I think
would shock a lot of people that I know
about Bobby Bobby Lee you look at just
google google a picture Bobby Lee and
then that guy played hockey you played
ice hockey yeah growing up in San Diego
which is crazy no I grew up in Minnesota
as a kid okay when I was a kid um that's
what you did yeah in Minnesota and then
when I was 12 we moved to San Diego and
I played for two years in San Diego yeah
you wouldn't expect you to somebody to
play down there I mean that's kind of
crazy
yeah but it was the San Diego chickens
it's a real team my brother and I play
both played yeah that's great because
you describe yourself as lazy though I
mean it's like you kind of feel like
you're just kind of like oh I'm the most
laziest person really yes
I really believe that really uh and I'm
nice and a joke but you have a great
career though huh it's not he could be
huge
I could be huge right if you I'll give
an example so we're doing the Kim's of
comedy right okay we just film the DVD
it's Bobby ken Jeong Kevin Shea myself
right now we're doing a show in San
Francisco the shows are sold out we got
to go down there and this is at a time
when this is like 10 years ago ken is
not ken Jeong right I haven't done
anything I haven't even had a Comedy
Central special Bobby's on MADtv madtv's
pretty darn popular it's on Comedy
Central
Bobby you walk anywhere Bobby people
know him they want to get a picture with
him he was you know you still are very
popular you come listen to everything
you're saying but at that time we needed
Bobby to be there right he's the show
that's the reason people come understand
it right so it's the day before the show
and I call Bobby and I go hey are you uh
are you excited about since San
Francisco he's like what are you talking
about I go dude we have a show in San
Francisco this weekend all of us because
all we do how am I gonna get there I
know dude you didn't get it ticket he
goes no I had to cancel my airline
ticket go over and I call I called Ken I
was like you won't believe this Bobby
doesn't have a ticket
Ken's like you make sure he gets there I
was like okay so I cancel my flight
drove over that was the only and I had
to literally get him in my car to drive
him to San Francisco to make sure that
he got there and me ask you a question
can I ask you a question okay did I end
up showing up to the gig yes because my
partner enough said oh you want to know
what happened when we're driving down
there though what so Bobby's sleeping
right I'm driving what just tell me this
when I hear say out loud oh no no that I
didn't do that on oh yeah why would I do
that no no no I look over and Bobby goes
dude you know this is true Bobby goes
keep driving keep driving
you're totally joking you're [ __ ]
around with me but he listened to me
okay okay is that on there is
I'm so disgusted at it I'm like we don't
talk for like an hour - am i that's not
funny mommy's laughing so we go do the
first show the first night we're in San
Francisco at the punchline okay I
finished my set I walked into the green
room the door shuts behind me nobody's
in the green room but I walk in and the
door like slams shut and I turn around
and Bobby's in the corner butt-naked he
goes hey Laurie and he'll are naked yeah
let me say this okay I'm gonna defend
myself I used to do things like that to
shock comics and just congratulations
thank you I want to control a situation
and that's how I do it right I'm Steve
Trevino who's a comic yeah I was in
Houston I'd never met him before he
picked me up from the airport he was
living in Texas at the time and this is
like 15 years ago maybe yeah and he
kicked me out of the car in the on the
freeway masturbating in the back right
now when you're doing that are you like
goofing off or you like I'm laughing I'm
giggling it's fun and he literally goes
broke get out on the side of a freeway
well any drove away you know what you
know like you watch Tommy Boy and
there's that thing where Chris Farley
goes Tommy want wingy like to this day
that will make me laugh it [ __ ] makes
me laugh so wait are you full-on going
at it or there no I'm not a rare one I'm
not erect okay number two Steve I think
he's doing it right now am i doing
number two it's it's it's just a joke
and also can I just say this over the
last five probably years I don't do
stuff like that anymore
yeah you really have tone it down
because you were yeah I was crazy you
were yeah yeah I think you still are
crazy but like you know
it was always been at a good way can you
tell everybody how you almost got fired
from MADtv well I did get fired and then
a day rehired me you be the [ __ ] the
pet my pants no no
what you didn't tell me that what are
you talking about where the new girl got
hired oh that wasn't what I I got sued
by didn't get I almost got soup I didn't
get fired the network had to call what
happened so this is this is like an
example like Bobby tells you the storage
like holy [ __ ] that's crazy but like to
you that was just another Tuesday at
that time yeah I mean I got in trouble
though so what did you do it was nuclear
the one morning you know how you know
you're you know you you're on a show and
you know sometimes you have rehearsals
early i doing yeah popular though Bobby
here's the one I would love to be on it
I want to talk about that later anyway
um so one morning I show up to
rehearsals and there's a girl sitting on
the couch in the rehearsal room I had no
idea who she is right but she's eating
yogurt you know and I was so tired you
know and so I just I sometimes when I'm
tired to make wrong decisions you know
and I grabbed the back of her head and I
farted in our face my mouth was over or
whatever that's how it hariya her
reaction she cried right started crying
what tears I don't know when tears come
out of the faintest cry right yeah yeah
right so um the wall you know because
I've never had that reaction before yeah
and in my head I'm like why did you do
that whatever and then Mike McDonald and
Ron Peterson approached me and then the
rod started pushing me and then Mike had
to take Ron Peterson and put him in a
headlock and bring him back
it was chaotic but then you know I
looked at the garage I'm sorry
and then like hours later I took a nap
and I woke up and everyone called yeah
it was like you know I mean you gotta
call us you know you might have to get a
lawyer or you're in [ __ ] big trouble
who was the girl I mean now that she's
one of my best friends now crista
Flanagan in fact you look at my
Instagram I have I just saw her a week
ago and we I have a photo with her Wow
my latest post was with Krista but she
later did Mad Men I mean she's a very
talented girl
one of my best friends and I've told
this story on Comedy Central before yeah
so it's like it's not something that's
I'm hiding room right you know it's just
that she can't enjoy yogurt anymore yeah
she hates you
one of my favorite stories that you've
ever told me can you tell us about that
I think was they did it depends on the
daytime anyone with I don't want to
really we'll talk about later there's
nothing bad in that maybe if I come back
to the next time there won't be a next
time why you don't be back can we talk
about us okay why don't you talk about
your experience as a came a comedy and
what why do you think that Kim's a
comedy never never worked out cuz cuz at
the time it was Latin Kings of Comedy
Kings of Comedy
and then Barry Katz and New Wave film
that Kim's economy what happened with
that I think that and this is something
that people are probably gonna hate when
I say but it's like I think that
specific Asians like if you like we were
a specifically Korean show and I don't
know if that is something that Filipinos
want to watch right right so I don't
feel like I feel like if you see a black
night you know men like an
african-american like comic show
african-americans will come out and
support it right you know one African
African see that can be like I'm from
South Africa and he's from Uganda so we
can't see the show right but we for some
of the Asians are divided the division
is there I mean the cultural divisions
or whatever right so it's like we didn't
it just wasn't a thing yeah we would you
show San Francisco yes we would do well
but then we did The Wiltern
and we ate it yeah in Koreatown in Korea
- oh yeah that you would assume that our
own people would come and support us and
when you say aided how many people Oh
buddy nobody claimed is poor really
we're in the Wilton theater and a what
is a like Live Nation just bet on us
they're like Oh with this sure do great
we'll put in create a second show
embarrassing
my parents flew in yeah really oh yeah
they were asking the ushers no korean
showed up yeah
no Korean showed up and I think if we
did it now now yeah yeah but I think
then no and it was really upsetting I
remember a bit being upsetting yet I
wanted that too or less than all of you
guys went on did a handful with headful
yeah that was it
you did awhile I was fun we did San
Francisco we did LA and that's pretty
much all I yes go like twice and yeah
that's my for the last the last San
Francisco well was really bad we did
this okay so Bobby and Ken have always
had this no other I love him
brotherly kind of affection for each
other
love them and at some point I think Ken
had developed some sense of a rivalry
with Bobby where's bob was on mad and
all this stuff and then Ken became like
the Asian Samuel Jackson were for a
moment in time he's in like everything
you'd go to a movie theater over the
summer and if he wasn't in the movie he
was in two trailers yeah crazy he was a
pepto-bismol commercial everything yeah
so we we do the show in San Francisco
and Bobby's not on it but then Bobby
flies down to come on a pop no to Ken
no okay here's what happened okay I'm
gonna tell you what happened just look
at me right now what this is what
happened what happened was is that when
we were doing the Kim's originally right
I asked for more money all right
and which gave I don't know about Ken
but I know the other guy he still
resentment resents me to the day to this
day when that other guy had no credits
he doesn't have credits up to this point
he doesn't deserve the amount of money
that I made on it and it's like you know
if we did if we were to do it Bobby was
the draw yeah if we were to do it now I
would I would even if Ken wanted more
money I'll go yeah he deserves more
money if you wanted more money you
deserve it but at the time they didn't
right right so it's like there was a
resentments occurring you were the draw
and then when we did then they kicked me
out of the tour you did and then I don't
everybody did well you did because you
were already
they're right and then when you said you
wanted me back in I was always pushing
yeah do you wanted me back in and so
Steve goes hey I'll secretly fly you to
San Francisco and you could just
surprise us and just go guys and you'll
go work this out right I know yeah all
right so he flies me over there I go in
the green room and they just didn't want
me there
Wow yeah well Ken Ken really took
exception to it and then there was a
moment where these two it looked like
they were gonna fight this fight
Kevin Shay's tapping me on a shore yeah
and I'm the only one that's like a ver
I'm six foot so Kevin's like you got to
break this up you got to break this up
I've been between Bobby and Ken and Cal
looked bad and I and I was like I was
ugly I was getting ready to start it and
then I I stopped for a minute I was like
this would be the cutest fight everybody
know it would be but then I broke it up
and then uh yeah we've never done a show
since so that the game's me ha me went
from four of you guys into three yeah
one weekend Oh cuz Ken had started kind
of on his way up and he said hey let's
do something so we we did it but there
was the exception we don't want Bobby
but I was always at the mindset look it
was the four of us start and let's
figure this out we're all we all started
together especially you can and I yeah i
mean you you were already in the that's
how i met you you on The Tonight Show
and I was in New York cities at New York
Comic and I saw him on The Tonight
should do a set he had just been cast in
MADtv and he killed absolutely killed
and I talked to my manager Barry Katz at
the time I go I saw this Korean dude
last night Bobby Leon he goes oh I know
him
gave me his number I called him up and I
got it when's the wins in in life when
does that ever happen a comedian you've
never met right from New York cause you
are the blue just to say I think your
Tonight Show said was amazing I mean as
soon as he called I just went well I'm
gonna know this guy I don't know about
to cry right now I really I really uh I
mean that's the nicest thing did he hit
you up for dates no it wasn't like that
it was just like one caller to another
like hey dude I just wanna let you know
that what you did was great
and I just went wow this guy's cool and
we've been ever since he'd that phone
call we've been very good friends and I
I've always adored them so I moved to LA
maybe like a year later and I met Bobby
I remember the first night I met him he
was at Dublin's which was used to be
this hot show in LA on Wednesday nights
and I went there to see him and I met
Ken Jeong there that night as well and
then we all all three of us became
friends and it's been a little different
since then you know I I think that we
could still do it and I'll tell you why
I've never even thought of I have you
have yes yeah because I don't like
losing yeah I like winning okay so it's
like for me it's like the timing was off
all right timing yeah for and also I've
changed you know over the years I've
grown up I don't really do the things I
used to do and I I'm pretty like you
know trustworthy I've fourteen years
sober Oh
in March sixth you know me and so I'm
like I've been in 12-step groups for 14
years I really work it so I've I've
grown up and I feel like if we did it
now we I would do it differently I think
that number one I would split the money
evenly or if they wanted more I would do
that and two I would take on my
responsibilities and I think that people
would actually come down in fact you
know there's every year in San Francisco
they do that Asian show with you know
other Asians never been invited I know
but I'm just saying maybe we should grow
more have to do right who's who's that
show it's cat fan I put a bunch of other
people I think that you and me and you
and Ken could just go and do our own one
but let me ask you because you you've
admitted a few minutes ago you're a lazy
guy
you're not very motor out yeah but is
that something that you thinking about
what put together that you would have
the motivation to be like heck yeah I'm
gonna put this together and get it
moving or you need somebody else to put
it together
sounds right yeah but you admitted 10
minutes ago that you're not you know
very much you know I'm just wondering
when I say I'm not motivated I mean by
the like for instance if I go on the
road pretty much every week it seems
like when they say you have to do press
I'm there I don't I'm not late I do it I
come home I don't complain I mean so in
terms of my responsibilities as a as a
business you know I conducted in in the
best way I can you know
and just in terms of like going out and
like hey you need to go to this party to
shake hands I don't do that right
whereas other people will do that you
know I mean I don't shake hands I don't
use social you know environments to get
a job which is probably my downfall
are you more if you're not working you'd
rather just be at home kind of hanging
out and not too much are you still the
social guy even when you're not
performing you'll see always in the gem
store those in the gym I'll give you an
example like I'm Rhea curring on a show
called love which is Judd Apatow Netflix
show okay I did three episodes but then
they are yeah I'm gonna do the second
season and um they called you know they
said you want to go to the wrap party
now normally I haven't been to every I
never go to a wrap party
but I've this year I've been like you
know what I'm gonna show up the things
like that and I saw I've changed in that
way you know but it's like I'm not
trying to be as lazy as I am but I'm
pretty lazy you know yeah but when it
comes to this Kim's a comedy thing I
don't think would be a lot of work you
know to be honest with you I think that
we would I would call Molly if we would
at San Francisco and I go listen me
Steven can't want to do one a one-off
show and then we did it
you know I don't know if ken does
stand-up and he can host I don't think
he does
yeah that would be the thing cuz I know
yes he's a TV star Gary is that what
you're trying to say Gary I'm gonna say
this that yeah you might not want to do
it now right but I'm just throwing it
out there
right so you're saying so literally a
couple seconds ago Bobby was talking
about this big grandiose tour doing it
together
it could really rip open the numbers and
now his plan is I'll make a call the
Molly maybe we get a one-nighter
I thought this is gonna be a big summer
tour and meanwhile Bobbie Molly
and see if it works you know I was like
this guy's good you gonna do a brand new
Woodstock George will call Molly and
then one night by the way if we went to
the will turn though the Koreans would
show up yeah this time yes you were sad
because I have a bigger road presence
now back then I never really did the
road you know I have hit these markets
so many times and I'm beginning the
beginning to draw really good you know I
mean so it's like I feel like on my end
you know I mean III could pull it off I
think on your end for sure you could
pull it off I think Ken can too you know
I think that it's uh it's a completely
different story now yeah I don't know
well that I mean I'm just throwing it
out there yeah in a year or two if you
want to do it I'm there yeah I have a
question when you went up to San
Francisco that night and you weren't
welcomed by the other guys I was
welcomed what one guy did they give you
a hotel that night or did you have to
fly the night oh I was gonna fly after
the first show back because I remember
them going they don't want me on the
show so you didn't know you had to go
back because they still there's no one
that flew me up there I got him a ticket
because I believed in I'm always a
believer in look this is how we started
it's the four of us this house sure
should end it this is what it should
always be it feels weird going on
without all four of us q that's that's
just my mentality so it meant that much
to me that I said I'll buy you a tickets
you can fly up if you're willing to come
up and maybe eat crow or just say hey in
front of the guys then for me it's not
about the money it's about getting the
group together that's what I believed it
what day was that I would love to know
when Steve actually bought you something
you strike me as a guy that take out
your openers and five nice dinners this
guy's so F&G but he's got yeah [ __ ] you
guys full Gary's really nice low price
what a nice person yeah I'd like to take
care of our guest but I just I'm just
I'm Tigerlily or whatever your shows
belly tiger belly
I play NHL and Battlefront right now
that's what ever you like Battlefront I
did when you first playing it you're
like awesome or whatever and then all of
a sudden you just realize you wait for a
pod to land you got to defend it and
then another pod lands you got to defend
it yeah and it just goes on and on and
on and on and on and there's no like
finish line there's no goal line there's
no like I want to be accelerating
towards so I want to win
no you're just kind of staving off
people fallout for my friend yeah all
right that's game
why don't you tell Bobby what I have I'm
a true video gamer won't you tell them
what I have in my house this slug yeah
bought a donkey kong machine full size
yeah and it's in his living room yeah
and what is your apartment like 800
square for 600 so literally this big
full-size arcade game takes up half of
the space there are Playstations Xbox
you can get at like game stuff and stuff
now this is the this the orig how many
games are there there's a chip on it
that plays like 15 other games Galaga
centipede and you play Doug a little bit
when is the last time you played it I
mean it's it's a long time because I'm
working on TV shows corporate gave
colleges I'm just running ragged all day
yeah I mean I'm just want to kill the
guys you're killing it I know yeah I
mean I so much work yeah not enough time
let me ask Bobby right so hold on hold
on yeah because you just brought that up
because yeah how much you're working and
everything yeah Bobby I'd like you to
read this review I'm Gary can and
website called gig masters yeah so Gary
was Gary did a gig on gig masters and my
very first gig on gig best whatever yeah
I'd like you to read this review this
review this is gary canada go ahead
master we read the stars out of 5 all
right so reviews are overall
satisfaction 1 out of 5 professionalism
3 out of 5 accommodating 3 out of 5
overall talent recommend one of the five
so was comp to the hotel
so I'm just gonna do I'm gonna treat it
as the guy to the hotel never showed up
for any of the activities access the
audience wanted reimbursement for a
tuxedo which he wasn't wearing arrived
immediately after the scheduled to
perform his material was stale he was
loud and obnoxious without being funny
even his Botox jokes kodox Oh tax
conventions all right even as Botox
jokes it was a cosmetic surgery
we're not funny and after about 15
minutes the president of our Foundation
asked him to leave
and excited without incident when you
read something like that how does that
feel well I got to tell you the night
that I did that show they told me when I
got hired dude this gig it was at a
hotel in Vegas it was at the four
seasons
and the woman who hired me said hey
listen I just want to let you know a lot
of those people in there are drunk
they're just they're probably not gonna
pay attention but you do the best you
can with it so I went in there the show
was not going well I suppose do 30
minutes they pulled me off after 15 and
the woman who hired me couldn't have
been any nicer after the the show I'm
sorry we wanted to for it to work out it
didn't we're so sorry boom boom boom
don't worry we'll pay you everything
will be great and then I don't know five
hours later that review goes up online
so I was just like crushed because I was
like wow this woman was stroking me off
yeah so she just wanted me to probably
just see a robot
she wrote that worried about everything
was great and then I had to fight to get
the rest of my money because they they'd
give me a deposit and they still owed me
like another seven hundred bucks and
they were fighting with me to pay it and
I finally I said listen I need my money
and and it took a while but I finally
got it Wow yeah and I was wearing the
tuxedo they were saying that I was not
but I was wearing the I bought it at the
Men's Wearhouse I never read reviews you
don't know I don't read comments reviews
because it's like it's unhealthy yeah
do you Steve yep why there's said I
believe sometimes there is constructive
criticism there is an inner review but
for the most part it's just people that
are upset with your unfunny changes
which is
I've gotten is not constructive that was
me taejeong 44 yeah by the way let me
ask you something
obviously you've done so much TV you're
still doing to understand up just that
the other thing what's your ultimate
like what what do you want to do be
doing in five years it's very much what
your thing what do you want to be doing
I don't have that that kind of goal
anymore I mean because if you set those
kind of goals in my opinion you'd be get
you get hurt right so for me it's like
as long as every year I'm doing
something a little different I'm happy
you know because I realized that I'm
happy with my career for many years I
wasn't I was like how come I'm not in
this movie how come this TV show didn't
get picked up but now I'm like you know
what I'm so glad that I didn't blow up
because I'm still getting opportunities
as life I'm new you know like I'll go to
an audition and they'll go wow that was
really good you know who is this guy
right and it's like I didn't make you
know a bad you know I don't have a bad
reputation you know I mean in in America
or in the world right I just I'm still
kind of people are still discovering me
and that's pretty exciting you know I um
I'm still getting invited to do really
cool [ __ ] [ __ ] and uh God guy Torry told
me that as long as every year you're
doing something different like and so
this year I played you know Guam that
was really fun wow yeah I did a couple
years ago it was a South Africa for two
months I did a bunch of shows there and
you're sitting there you know in South
Africa like you know walking around with
giraffes and stuff and you're going wow
this is really weird and cool you know I
mean that's life you know because I've
know so many guys I'm not gonna name
names that blew up huge and that fall
down right they burned every Bridge when
they got down and there's just no way up
and I'd rather be in my situation than
that situation rather than be in danger
no Elliott Oh Dana
yeah he wears the floral shop over on
Western but you know you you're right I
mean I love him yeah I love Dan I do too
yeah big fan but I'm a big fan but um
you know I our show yes no fight you
guys gonna go yeah well you went to his
house and screamed at him on his lawn in
the morning yeah well I know oh you
wanted to bring up his Cheech and Chong
story talked about it though yeah I've
talked about it you know on meirin's
podcast all that stuff is healthy I
really do believe that yeah yeah but
when comics you know me have conflict
and they work it out in that way is I
think very healthy well I'll say this
when it happened it happened we were a
lot younger than I don't know the
reasoning is why somebody would say or
do or whatever but the fact of the
matter is that I saw Dane you know three
or four years ago and we just I I asked
him hey could we just walk around the
bend and just chat for a minute and he
immediately apologized and once he did
that it was just like everything any any
even slight resentment I had was gone
and I've seen him out a bunch of times
it were super cool with each other yeah
you know I was annoyed hockey with him
of you know once or twice it is amazing
to as you get older how you know all
that little petty [ __ ] kind of goes
away and everybody kind of like puts
their ego aside people become a little
more humble you mean even you know it
it's also knowing your place in the
world I think when you're younger you
really don't know it's like where do I
fit in Who am I what you know and
there's just so much going on and just
like you'd have a comfortability and in
your own security even you know in your
living situation and your you know in
your career and I think as time goes on
it's like you slowly start to chisel the
fat you discover okay I'm a little more
comfortable with myself I know my place
in the world and I I don't think you
have that another thing is is this that
you think as a young comic that if you
attain certain goals or these things
that it'll fix you sure right so you
if I just get into a movie or if I just
got on a TV show and what you realize is
that it doesn't right right it's just
it's like a drug really right it fades
away and you want more and it's
unhealthy you know it nothing in there's
there's no job in the world there's not
an amount of money in the world that's
gonna fix me yeah but it's like she's
like you were saying you're in Guam and
all these giraffes are walking around
it's like yeah I mean you look at so
many people that are doing like a
regular office job a day job a desk job
that will never experience that and you
know we get to do something different
all the time you don't mean it's like
yes never but I'm gonna defend comics in
the sense that like you know if you take
bigger risks in life you get big things
right it's like you know I know a lot of
guys that go hey you know you should
feel blessed and you know you're lucky
and I feel lucky but I walked through a
lot of fear mm-hmm you know I mean and I
did a lot of pressure situations like
when you had the Tonight Show that's not
fun especially in the tooth year I was -
that year mm yeah I was young I was
scared but I did it you know and it's
like you know I did that you know it's
like I'm not saying that I'm different
than any other human being I'm just
saying that you know if you're listening
you got to take big risks yeah you know
live in the moment right that all we
have is the moment but you got to go out
and live life and if you're if you want
to do something you got to do it and I
think that if everyone lived
unless you're Isis don't do that
whatever I stopped doing that but like
other other than Isis you remain
everything fine yeah yeah yeah well
that's why I truly love you I love I
love you I I honestly I swear to God I
really do Bobby Lee's not only great
dude great comic but when you're at The
Comedy Store clearly the best intros you
always give such a great job I always
give me the intros but I you always give
me a great intro yeah why don't you give
me a good intro I started to recently oh
yeah yeah you know why I give good
intros why I hate that intros you know
who gives bad intros who-who used to
hear Marc Maron
yeah and now he's good because he knows
how I feel about it you know he's he
doesn't do it anymore I mean there are
comics that do it and I just let them
know I go
when you call me a dancing monkey oh my
god what yeah who said that I mean there
have caught this guy it has high energy
and he's a dancing monkey
oh that's [ __ ] and then they bring you
up it's like thanks for no [ __ ] pitch
I can't hear a small but I have given
you bad intros it's people can tell we
were friends and I'm [ __ ] around yeah
and we banter on say that's fine I love
that right but when somebody doesn't win
they're condescending towards you
towards you and your act in general yeah
and then and they also negate the things
you've done
hey dude I've done way more than you
it's when I say all these things can you
just look at Gary yeah talking to you
Gary you'll give good intros I do go oh
no no no the shitty says about me yeah
that's why I heard even times sometimes
I'll give you a shitty one but I do mix
it up when I know you're mad oh god how
dare you I will it's like ladies and
gentlemen you picked a great weekend of
cash in your group on you know from
nothing like I'm the headline dude
backstage you angry I don't get angry
just like it's fine but I'm like I'll go
up I'll do my stuff but it's like yeah
it's like dude no no but but Larry
listen no no no I guess he's hosting no
I heard about that yes
yeah so let me ask you something right
yes but that's not right but we have a
great we have a great show I've done
that on a handful occasion but like even
tape and Sullivan's son it's much like
when I bring you up he just ladies and
gentlemen this next guy graduated from
the Rob Schneider Academy of Dramatic
Art ski bar it's like that's the stuff
it's also funny too because we I was
talking to fraser-smith about this last
night it's funny because no matter how
much I would [ __ ] on you whether it was
the intro or at Sullivan & Son
the minute you would try to zing me back
the audience would boost Steve because I
just had him on my side and then when
you would try to zing me back they would
boo you and you'd be like what that why
you yelling at me now I mean I was just
it was absolutely crazy just to kind of
see that whole dynamic but I will
definitely build it up because oh and I
think it's important it is I really do I
just want to say thank you for having me
on Sullivan songs it was a really fun
story are we have to talk that off
story-arc and i really appreciate it
awfully air it's really nice love you
Bobby but we're not done yet
what God will give away and we have a
sponsor yeah cut that [ __ ] you do the to
do the what's the giveaway okay by the
way we're doing a cool giveaway we're
both friends with Ellen DeGeneres here
and actually what we're going shopping
again we go shopping together we buy
clothes together I love him we are
giving a guest listener and a guest a
chance to come out to LA and go to an
Ellen 12 days of Christmas show so I'm
not even giving with prices we're giving
them the tickets yes so we will fly you
out and then everything else is on you
but you don't get to go to the 12 days
of Christmas show through Ellen and
we'll take caller eight phrase that page
service the phrase that pays a couple of
tickets to the Ellen 12 days of
Christmas show which is coming up so
that's very exciting right by the way
Steve we have a sponsor today we do we
actually have a sponsor but this is
great we're so excited about this
today's sponsor is audible.com which is
awesome they have more than 180,000
audio books and spoken word audio
products and we are actually giving a 30
day trial subscription to our listeners
if they go to audible.com backslash dojo
just so you know are you big audiobooks
guy I've listened to them on occasion on
road trips so I'll definitely do it they
definitely are the best what I wanted
our listeners to know I love self-help
books let's do the greatest write that
these audible books have chapter
navigation sleep mode there's a
30-second rewind there's a button free
mode it just it's really really cool so
all you have to do is go to audible.com
and backslash dojo like I said audible
is offering a free 30 day trial
membership just go to audible.com slash
dojo for your pick of over 180,000 audio
programs download a title free and start
listening it's that easy and enjoy it
anytime I take a like a long road trip
especially during the holidays or
something I always load up on something
I remember
when you're my well when my wife and I
were driving here for Chicago we listen
to The Kite Runner oh yeah crying in
Colorado oh you are yeah it's it's so
depressing
can I borrow ten dollars I'm being real
god I love you no I need to borrow $10
oh yeah but really I'm being real it's
what's great I mean cuz there's books
about broadcasters entertainers that
magazine and newspaper publishers
business information providers it's it's
actually really really cool unlike a
streaming or rental service audible you
own the book which is great that's
awesome yes audible.com backslash dojo
check it out thank you to our guest
Bobbie Lee oh honey it's so funny you
can listen to his podcast on all things
comedy as well called Tiger belly he is
literally one of my favorite beings we
thank you guys for listening at Cannon
comedy at Steve Byrne live keep up with
us keep the reviews coming in champion
is on Netflix and don't forget Saturday
February 6 Chicago filming my fourth
hour special 7 and 10 o'clock at Lincoln
Hall go to LH - st.com for tickets thank
you guys so much Pittsburgh New Year's
Eve adios